aire cette affaire se clashche non plus
et il y a donc une loi qui a été adoptée
très récemment voilà deux députés de
députés se sont emparés du sujet au
printemps pour effectivement encadrer
davantage le secteur d'ailleurs les
clashes avec Booba ont été directement à
l'origine de leur proposition de loi ce
sont ces députés qui l'ont dit eux-mêmes
le texte vise à créer un statut une
définition de ce que c'est qu'un
influenceur il était temps on le dit
depuis le début de cette émission mais
ils sont quand même 150000 en France la
loi qui aussi donne des interdits sur
certaines publicités on va voir la liste
c'est très important la loi interdit les
publicités faisant la promotion de la
chirurgie de la médecine esthétique de
certains produits services financiers on
le disait avec Nabil également la loi
interdit l'abstention thérapeutique
c'est très important encore la nicotine
ça c'est des ajouts qui ont été faits au
Sénat ou encore des abonnements à des
conseils ou à des pronostics sportifs
enfin les influenceurs devront indiquer
clairement la mention publicité ou
collaboration commerciale sur leur
contenu promotionnel c'est l'un des
points de la loi qui est le plus
compliqué à appliquer à l'heure qu'il
est pour ses influenceurs et créateurs
de contenu et d'ailleurs ces
influenceurs et bien ils ont critiqué
hein dernièrement cette loi he tous les
acteurs du secteur qui étaient
rassemblés c'est trop compliqué ont-il
dit au gouvernement c'est le message
qu'ils ont fait passer il y a quelques
jours en septembre lors d'une rencontre
entre 130 créateurs de contenu et le
ministre de l'Économie lors d'un
événement organisé par la fédération
professionnelle de l'influence s'appelle
lumic il viennent de s'organiser
justement hein ce ce syndicat on a
beaucoup de questions auxquelles on n'
pas forcément de réponse à par exemple
insisteré Marie Lopez alias enjoy Phenix
qui compte 6,3 millions d'abonnés sur
Instagram le gouvernement de son côté a
promis vous le voyez de clarifier la loi
et même de mettre en place un groupe de
travail sur le sujet Bruno Le Maire a
même dit à ses influenceurs vous êtes
une force économique majeure de notre
pays il a dit il faut impérativement que
l'on corrige le tir à propos de cette
proposition de loi il a même promis une
prochaine rencontre avec ses
influenceurs dans les 6 mois Tam merci
merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes ces
explications et nous sommes également en
visio avec Amel gaker qui est signatrice
Union centriste du pas decalis qui vient
d'être réélu qui est rapporteur de ce
texte qui a encadré l'activité des
influenceurs Amel gaker d'abord euh
votre réaction à ces propos de Bruno
leemire qui promet donc de clarifier la
loi qui dit que si cette loi est source
de complexité bah il va falloir
la changé et que c'est à ce moment-là
une mauvaise
loi alors j'ai pas entendu dire bonjour
à tous pardon pour commencer moi je n'ai
pas entendu dans ces propos que cette
loi était mauvaise ce que j'ai entendu
c'est qu'elle nécessitait peut-être de
la clarification ce que je dis surtout
c'est que cette loi et vous l'avez très
bien rappelé vous avez évoqué assez
précisément son contenu contenu donc
quand même assez clair elle visait elle
avait une vertu quand même essentiel qui
était vraiment d'encadrer un secteur le
secteur de l'influence commerciale qui
est aujourd'hui en plein développement
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas nouveau hein
l'une des personnes présentes sur le
plateau l'a dit tout à l'heure hein ça
fait maintenant bien plus de 10 ans que
le secteur de l'influence commerciale en
tout cas existe mais c'est vrai qu'à
aujourd'hui il est vraiment il se
développe de façon exponentielle donc le
statut ou la définition en tout cas de
ce secteur là n'existait pas
juridiquement donc nous lorsque avec les
députés de la porte et vogetta lorsque
nous avons travailler sur le texte euh
nous savions qu'il s'agissait d'une
première pierre à l'édifice une première
pierre essentielle et j'étais heureuse
d'entendre également une de vos invités
qui disait que on avait déjà aujourd'hui
euh un je dirais des conséquences assez
positives puisque nous l'état d'esprit
en tout cas dans lequel moi en tant que
rapporteur j'ai souhaité travailler avec
mes collègues sur ce texte c'était
c'était de clarifier mais aussi de faire
preuve de pédagogie parce que des règles
il en existaient déjà euh sur des règles
en termes de promotion en terme de
publicité des biens et services sauf que
beaucoup aujourd'hui d'influenceurs ne
les connaissaient pas tout simplement
donc c'est pédagogie et puis
transparence et ça c'est aussi un
élément qui nous paraissait essentiel
avec plusieurs éléments dont la mention
publicité ou collaboration commerciale
ce qui était loin loin d'être existant
acquis alors j'entends bien que
peut-être dans la mise en pratique dans
la mise en place cela est compliqué mais
à aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a
vraiment l'avant et l'après de cette loi
certainement encore des choses à
travailler mais encore une fois dans le
contexte de développement de ce secteur
elle a aujourd'hui vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'avantage Amel gaka restez
avec nous on va aussi faire réagir nos
invités sur ce plateau myiam roche vous
dites aussi he que la loi elle était
elle est nécessaire mais vous constatez
qu'il y a quand même des flous
donnez-nous quelques exemples sur
lesquels vous estimez que cette loi pour
l'instant elle n'est pas suffisante
alors il y a des flous sur le côté
gifting quand on est créateur de contenu
on a l'habitude de recevoir des produits
gratuitement quand une marque sort un
nouveau je sais pas un nouveau fond de
teint un nouvel appareil photo et cetera
dans la loi il est préciser que ce
gifting aujourd'hui il va falloir le
déclarer aux impôts le problème c'est
que les créateurs de cont ça parait
normal hein comme ça mais ce qui paraît
logique mais les créateurs de contenu ne
le font ne l'ont jamais fait jusqu'à
présent et ont quelques soucis sur bah
comment est-ce qu'on va devoir déclarer
ces ces produits offerts sachant queon
n' pas forcément accès au au prix on
sait pas combien ça ça ça coûte
réellement de se les procurer et surtout
la question
c'était ça peut être vérifié je pas le
prix d'un produit ça peut être vérifié
mais le le le le le la problématique
c'est par exemple quand ils sont invités
en voyage souvent ils sont invités par
des marques à découvrir un produit à
l'étranger ou à par à partir en voyage
quelques jours une semaine et cetera sur
le côté voyage la marque ne leur précise
jamais combien véritablement ce voyage
leur coûte alors qu'aujourd'hui quand
ils acceptent ce type de partenariat
aujourd'hui il va falloir qu'il le qui
le déclare qui déclare ce gifting donc
il y a ce côté qui était assez flou et
dans comme votre collègue l'a dit tout à
l'heure à la réunion de lumic il y avait
aussi des comptables qui étaient
présents et qui disaient que bah au
niveau comptabilité il y avait aussi des
zones de flou savoir comment faire
véritablement euh a est-ce que comment
vous vous réagissez à à cette loi est-ce
que c'était une une bonne chose elle
était elle était nécessaire est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'elle a un peu
stigmatisé aussi peut-être votre votre
activité
P je pense que l'idée est très bonne en
soif enfin je pense que c'est même
important de le faire après c'est pas
étonnant que ce soit compliqué de
réformer ce genre de choses parce que
c'est de mondes qui communiquent
absolument pas entre eux c'est très
souvent des gens qui travaillent dans
des bureaux qui regardent peut-être la
télévision et cetera et ils connaissent
absolument pas le métier de créateur de
contenu d'influenceur et donc forcément
il va falloir communiquer ça va prendre
du temps enfin ça me paraît pas je
trouve ça assez normal en fait que ça
prenne autant de temps normal qu' a des
trou dans la raquette aussi puisse y
avoir des des flous des choses B tous
les cas peuvent pas êre prév non plus
norm c'est normal j'ai l'impression que
c'est il y a une communication en tout
cas euh on verra d'ici 6 mois donc c'est
assez bon signe tant que les gens
communiquent je pense que c'est bon
signe Amel gaker je reviens à vous
est-ce que c'est c'est par
particulièrement compliqué pardon pour
un parlementaire de légiférer sur un
secteur vous l'avez dit il y a quand
même une dizaine d'années mais qui reste
quand même récent et puis qui est très
mouvant aussi dans dans ces
pratiques alors c'est compliqué ça vient
d'être très justement dit hein c'est
vraiment un secteur qui bien sûr qui
explose mais qui est aussi extrêmement
euh différent dans dans sa nature
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on parle
d'influenceur vous avez parlé de 150000
influenceurs on a seulement 15 %
d'influenceurs qui le font à temps plein
le reste ce sont des influenceurs qui
peuvent le faire de façon parfois très
périodique dans des secteurs très
diverses dans le secteur en effet de la
finance dans le secteur de la santé dans
le secteur donc oui c'est un secteur
extrêmement large en pleine mutation
véritablement donc oui c'est complexe
mais nous législateurs vous vous le
savez hein dans la façon dont on travail
sur les textes on le fait pas seul loin
de là et on le fait pas dans des bureaux
les auditions on les a vu hein
d'ailleurs fa dans des auditions moi
j'ai reçu j'ai j'ai invité vous savez
vous avez parlé de de de Booba et de
Magalie Berda pour on m'a posé la
question de savoir si c'était important
que je la rencontre ou pas
gar tout ce qui se disait et cetera mais
moi aujourd'hui mon rôle c'était
d'écouter tout le monde donc j'ai invité
tout le monde Magalie Berda a répondu à
l'invitation euh on a écouté j'ai invité
Booba qui a décliné l'invitation ce que
je respecte complètement mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on le fait à partir
évidemment d'audition dans tous les
secteurs également l'umique exactement
qu'on a reçu également donc oui c'est
complexe parce que ça reste des domaines
dans voilà encore une fois qui évolue
très vite euh qui sont très larges mais
sur lequel on peut à aujourd'hui et
c'est ce qu'on a réussi à faire en tout
cas poser un cadre qui forcément sera
évolutif et heureusement qu'il sera
évolutif et et oui oui c'est très
rassurant de savoir que et et c'est
l'état d'esprit encore une fois dans
lequel nous sommes il continua à évoluer
à s'adapter et aujourd'hui je suis
persuadé qu'il y a des questions ou des
sujets qui n'ont pas été intégrés dans
cette loi mais qui vont l'être très très
vite donc il faut vraiment rester agile
et puis et puis vraiment rester en lien
en effet avec ceux qui pratiquent cette
activité commerciale euh Marie on vient
de par parler à l'instant de ce clash
Booba Magalie Verda toute
cette cette chasse aux influ voleur qui
a été lancé est-ce que vous c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui vous a permis
bah de découvrir à ce moment-là les
dérives quel impact ça ça a eu vous sur
votre consommation peut-être des des
réseaux sociaux euh premier vous en
aviez déjà consru avant premier point
j'aimerais vraiment peut-être rappeler
ou je pense qu'on est plutôt d'accord
là-dessus que c'est vraiment une
minorité là vraiment les flu voleur les
pratiques commerciales complètement
fallacieuses et illicites c'est vraiment
une minorité et en fait on s'est
beaucoup concentré là-dessus donc on a
eu un peu tendance j'ai l'impression en
tout cas dans mon dans de mon point de
vue en tant que consommatrice de contenu
que tout le monde tous les influenceurs
tout le monde était mauvais personne ne
faisait les choses correctement mais il
y avait juste en fait un un vide
juridique et législatif qu'il fallait
venir remplir et donc B premier point
deuxème point euh j'ai jamais vraiment
consommé ce genre de contenu mais on les
voyait dans tous les cas voyait on se
doutait enfin je veux dire ça ça sent
pas très bon quand même des fois il y a
certaines recommandations ou promotions
qui sont pas les plus on va dire les
plus vous n'étiez pas naïve non je
n'étais pas naïve et et mais je pense
enfin je peux tout à fait comprendre
qu'on puisse bah vouloir acheter un
produit quelqu'un vous le recommande
justement il y a aussi cet aspect aspect
d'affect oh ben vous êtes fan de cette
personne elle vous le recommande très
souvent en plus il y a une mise en
situation ah j'utilise tel produit je
sais pas ça ça du maquill age ils vont
le mettre hop on se filme regardez il y
a un super beau je sais pas un super
beau résultat ah bah oui ben bien
évidemment qu'on a envie deacheter on se
projette aussi puisque la personne va
l'utiliser ça va pas être une pub à la
télé la pub à la télé on sait que c'est
de la pub pertinemment euh la la il va y
avoir des retouche il y a la il y a la
photo il y a la caméra il y a le
maquillage euh sur les réseaux sociaux
justement on est généralement le
présupposé c'est le postula c'est que on
est sur une base de de vérité parce que
les réseaux sociaux il y a pas de filtre
aujourd'hui il y en a h mais donc aussi
dans le le le discours qu'on peut avoir
on on pourrait en effet tomber là-dedans
on va dire une une toute dernière
question àel gaker euh est-ce que ce qui
manque aussi dans dans dans le contexte
de cette loi ce sont les les les
gendarmes pour pour chasser les voleurs
les les effectifs pour pouvoir et bien
effectivement chasser les personnes qui
qui qui font des infractions à la loi
alors ça a été ça a été relevé hein dans
le texte ça a vraiment fait partie des
débats au Sénat également d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée nationale
c'était d'évoquer la notion de moyens il
y a deux choses la première et je
rejoins madame qui vient de s'exprimer
là-dessus hein c'est c'est de surtout
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
panier et et cette loi a comme vertu de
protéger autant les influenceurs
commerciaux que les consommateurs ça je
le rappelle parce que c'est vraiment
dans cet état d'esprit là qu'on l'
engagé mais ça veut dire aussi derrière
et bien durcir entre guillemets le
régime de sanction pour ceux qui ne
respecteraient pas les règles donc cette
petite minorité qui ne respecterait pas
les règles donc durcir le les sanctions
oui mais avec quel moyen donc forcément
c'est un sujet que nous avons mis sur la
table notamment dans dans le cadre de la
DGCCRF aujourd'hui qui est compétente en
la matière donc toutes les autorités
compétentes en la matière donc oui ça a
été évoqué et l'engagement qui avait été
pris d'ailleurs par par Madame la minist
c'était de de d'évoquer ce sujet-là
également dans le projet de loi de
finances qui sera présenté en novembre
sur lequel on on abordera aussi cette
question de moyens parce que oui les
obligations c'est bien mais si on n' pas
les moyens pour le contrôler ce n'est
pas possible et bien merci beaucoup
merci Amel gakard d'avoir participé à
cette émission Michael Stora il nous
reste vraiment quelques
minutes la question c'est aussi de
savoir s'il faut pas aller plus loin
dans cette loi quel autre public il faut
protéger est-ce qu' il faut notamment
accorder une attention particulière ben
je pense au au public jeune aux ados aux
enfants vous vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure non mais je je trouve vraiment
et en effet ça rejoint cette idée dès
qu'on met des lois sur finalement une
illusion d'expression libre c'est un peu
comme ça que reposit Internet et
finalement on se rend compte que
finalement la liberté n'existe que parce
qu'il y a un cadre c'est assez banal et
donc l'idée de créer petit à petit des
cadres permet justement de ne pas
rentrer dans cette sorte de faux
semblant qui en effet à la télé c'est
clair il y a la pub et puis on sait que
c'est de la pub et en même temps il y a
des pubs qui sont incroyablement B et
donc c'est la question c'est comment
est-ce que sur internet des personnes
les influx voleurs comme vous dites il y
en a peu mais elles ont souvent
énormément d'abonnés c'est ça la
question et on sait que souvent les
abonnés souvent et et souvent leurs
abonnés sont très jeunes dis jeunes je
sais pas jusqu'à quel âge on est jeune
mais néanmoins jeune parfois ados ou
enfant et donc ça c'est vrai que là
l'idée de mettre une loi permet pour
celui qui regarde de se dire tiens ah
oui ça c'est donc c'est faux mais en
même temps celle qui le présente donc il
y a un rapport symbolique que je trouve
très bon très sain et je pense que même
pour les influenceurs c'est intéressant
aussi parce que au-delà de leur modèle
économique ça leur permet de dire ok
donc là c'est un rôle que je joue et
donc à partir de ce momentl je ne suis
pas simplement cette sorte de personnage
hybride ou à force de se filmer tout le
temps parce que parfois il faut poster
énormément de vidéos les personnes ne
savent plus trop ce qu'il en est de leur
réalité leur moins interne et je suis
parfois inquiet de la santé mentale
aussi des influenceurs de certains
influenceurs par que d'après moi il
peuvent faire des burnout on l'a vu
c'est-à-dire qu'à force de développer
une sorte de moi virtuel
impressionnant où le modèle écomomique
tu était pas toujours très clair ben
parfois le mois réel peut s'effondrer
sorte de tension comme ça ce qu'on
appelle nous en psychologie le faux self
le faux self d'un acteur d'un chanteur
on sait parce qu'il joue dans un cadre
précis mais l'influenceur lui c'est tout
le temps au quotidien un un mot pour
conclure aussi Miriam làdessus parce que
vous aussi vous dites qu'il faut quand
même aussi notamment protéger sans doute
les plus jeunes et que c'est là-dessus
qu'il y a encore un chantier à faire
d'un point de vue législatif
effectivement je pense que il y a aussi
un besoin de formation auprès des plus
jeunes pour peut-être leur expliquer
comment utiliser les réseaux sociaux ce
qu'on peut y trouver qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire collaboration commerciale sur
une story des des créateurs de contenu
parce que nous avec le recul qu'on qu'on
a on peut comprendre mais quelqu'un qui
est peut-être beaucoup plus jeune n'a
pas la même logique et la même réflexion
que que nous le mot de la fin comment
vous allez capter notre attention
jusqu'à la fin ah là j'ai pas d'idée
pour la fin vous avez vu c'est une
rupture de
pattern je vous ai bien appris du coup
vous avez vu ça j'apprends vite 52
minutes ça m'a suffit merci merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participer à cette émission on vous
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro d'avoir 20
[Musique]
ans